this great big story was made possible
by shell
make the future
the wheel
a perfect function invented in the stone
age
to this day the wheel provides the same
function as it did those thousands of
years ago but one man is flipping
everything we knew about the wheel on
its end
my name is michael bertoff i'm not an
engineer but i did what most engineers
wish they could
when i was a little kid i like to take
things apart and see what they're made
out of
i tried to make something new out of
them and i still like doing it to this
day
in 2012 i was running an hr company and
i turned on the movie tron i was
drinking a coffee and i thought those
are very cool motorcycles in the movie
they're called light cycles and they
have these hollow wheels and i remember
thinking well i'm not an engineer but
couldn't we do something useful with
that empty space i imagine you could put
things in the wheel that lived outside
of it with an electric wheel for example
the motor and the battery
[Music]
a wheel of powers itself is a much more
universal wheel than a wheel that needs
something else to power it
make it super compact super efficient
and that's really what inspired me
pretty much everyone said it was
impossible they said that if it could be
done it would have been done already by
a real engineer so i ignored them and i
quit my job and then i met dakota decker
we ended up leaving spacex to build the
wheel together with me
dakota and i spent about two years
before we came to the version that we
put up for retail
it's a much more compact design
it takes up the same space as a regular
wheel but it's got everything in it the
entire power train the battery the motor
the computer this wheel is extremely
environmentally friendly it's electric
power and it's a very efficient use
we have made thousands of bicycles into
affordable electric vehicles all over
the world
we see that we can contribute to the
future of transportation with the
georgia wheel we see vehicles that
nobody has ever made before
being able to be made now
imagine a car imagine the possibilities
when you take all the guts out of a car
because you just don't need them anymore
the opportunities really are endless
[Music]
you